so i have some bad news about apple's
brand new magsafe
wireless chargers and because of this
for me
personally this thing is going to be a
lot less useful than i expected
it might be for you as well now we all
know that because of this new magsafe
charger
the iphone 12s can finally fast charge
wirelessly
at 15 watts which is fantastic
but along with that this supports
standard qi charging so it could support
a variety of devices
just like apple lists on their website
now today this morning it came in
plugged it into my pro display xdr which
has usb
type c and i went ahead and i set down
my iphone 11 pro max on top and it
started charging
like usual this thing's actually not
connected right now but pretend it
started charging up
everything is going just fine now 10
minutes later i go ahead and i pick up
my
phone and to my surprise their
percentage
only went up by two percent and yes
it was aligned perfectly like many of
you out there i'm expecting
7.5 watts out of this charger that's
what multiple tech websites said
and that's a standard for a 10 15 qi
charger
and that's exactly what the iphone 11
pro will accept so out of my curiosity i
went ahead and purchased a well-rated
charging app
and ran one of the many tests that i'm
going to mention
my first result was 2.98
watts now i was expecting 7.5
and at 2.98 that means that it takes
4 minutes to charge this phone by one
percent now at the same time i noticed
a few things the first was that my phone
was already pretty charged so i thought
hmm
maybe it is limiting my wireless
charging because my battery is pretty
well
charged already and the second thing is
you know i'm plugging into my pro
display xdr
maybe it's not able to provide the full
wattage that this new charger needs
it does say on the box that you need a
20 watt usb
type c charger not the 18 watts the new
20 watts so i decided to fix
both of these issues right away i
grabbed a 20 watt
adapter plugged in the new mac save
charger and picked up
my iphone se aligned it perfectly and
started my
test after about 10 minutes i got my
result and it was a shockingly low
1.8 watts now surely this can't be right
this phone can accept 7.5 watts and it's
completely
cool and the battery is almost dead so
it should be able to accept
the whole 7.5 watts from the charger
right that's when i grabbed my really
cheap
charging stand and i'll go ahead and
link this in the description by the way
put my iphone se on top of here and test
it again
and i got a shocking 8.4
watts taking an average of just 39
seconds
for each percentage point gained
compared to three minutes
i gotta say i couldn't believe this so i
tested again
with the magsafe charger making sure
that it is perfectly aligned
and this time i got an even lower 1.49
watts
after this i did a bunch of testing i
grabbed an iphone 10s
i used a different coil to make sure i
also tested out
my note 20 and i took my mophie charger
that apple has been selling
since launch and the results were
interesting
now i don't know about you but i wasn't
only planning to charge my iphone 12
with this charger
i want to replace multiple chargers i
have in my house
with these new ones so i can fast charge
my new iphone 12s
and then at the same time i could toss
my earpods on here i can toss
other devices such as android phones or
older iphones
because these things are so much nicer
sleeker
smaller and better looking i have a few
standard ones
like this mophie so i tested the iphone
se on it
and it got 5.5 watts so just a bit shy
of 7.5
and my iphone 11 pro max got 7.14 watts
despite being pretty well charged over
80
going back to the magsafe charger i
continue to get between
two to three watts charging the iphone
11 pro max with the 20 watt brick
just like i did when it was connected to
my pro display xdr
and no more than two watts on the iphone
se
going as low as 0.96 watts
which is insane my iphone 10s was also
between 1 and 3 watts on magsafe
instead of 7.5 watts next it was time
to test out the note 20 which can accept
15 watt fast charging
but i didn't expect magsafe to offer
that here
since obviously it's designed for the
iphone 12 but i was hoping for
at least 7.5 i couldn't find the same
app but i found one that read the amps
coming in
and instead of getting about 1.3 from my
cheap qi charger
i got about a tenth of that with
constant disconnects
even though it was aligned perfectly
that means that instead of taking
three and a half hours to charge with
seven and a half watts
it would take 13 hours or longer on the
note 20
ultra and between 6 to 12 hours for
iphones
now it's planning to charge a variety of
devices with this magsafe charger
even though i know it won't magnetically
align like it will with the iphone 12
and one of those devices are my earpods
pros
now these things take roughly three
hours to charge
with a cheap qi charger but if you
decide to use
your magsafe charger and it maxes out at
those three watts that i saw
that will take roughly five hours and if
it runs
at just one watt like i saw at times
with the iphone
se that means that it will take 15
hours to charge your earpods compared to
just
two hours plugging them in with a
standard lightning cable
so what did we learn well first off
don't expect
the magsafe charger to give you 7.5
watts of charging
that you typically will use a need for
an iphone 8 or an iphone se
10 10 s 11 all of those devices
or even the five watts that the airpod
pros are designed to work with
i know multiple people have mentioned
this in comments websites are mentioning
this
and that's just what you would expect
because that's what the other iphones
allow and that's what most qi chargers
will give you
i don't know why this is but in reality
we're getting
less than half the wattage from this new
magsafe charger
and at times maybe eight times less
than what i would expect plugging into
one of these devices
and that's a bummer if you were like me
and you wanted to swap a few of your
wireless chargers
to a nice new sleek thin maxi charger so
it takes up less
room and it looks sleeker and that would
give you the ability to have
mag safe for your iphone 12 and you can
fast charge your iphone 12
but then at the same time you can drop
down an android phone
or maybe somebody else in your family
your spouse or your kids
have older iphones that have wireless
charging they can also come in
you know pop it on like that and get
wireless charging as well
well that's not a good idea unless you
really don't like whoever
else is going to be using this charger
and you
want to give them say roughly 6
wireless charging in half hour of charge
time which is
really frustrating you definitely don't
want to replace your other wireless
chargers
or charge other devices and things like
airpods on them
now to point out the apple never said
that this thing can output 7.5 watts
so they're not technically lying about
anything but they are giving us
a list of iphones that are supported
which are all of the wirelessly charging
iphones
so i wish they would disclose how slow
of a charge you're gonna get
if you actually decide to wirelessly
charge those devices
with this new magsafe charger in my
opinion
it really shouldn't be advertised for it
because it is just
too dang slow pretty much useless
let me know your thoughts about these
new mac safe chargers
were you expecting them to put out at
least 7.5
watts if you're spending 40 bucks on the
charger potentially another 20
on a 20 watt usb type-c power brick
i think 7.5 watts is really the standard
these days or even
three four years ago so for me
this is a huge bummer and that means
that i still have to keep
my previous wireless chargers which i
didn't want to do
and that means that the magsafe chargers
are really only useful
for the iphone 12s and at that point
i might as well just keep my lightning
cable there to fast charge that device
and then use the slower wireless
charging for a bunch of other devices or
just for
convenience thank you guys for watching
make sure you guys enable those
notifications because we have a lot of
great iphone 12 and 12 pro videos coming
up by the time you're watching this the
iphones are in our hands
so we have some awesome content that is
in the works thank you guys for watching
click that circle above to subscribe
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video